[Music]
hi my name is markiplier I'm here at
what's the name of this ranch Los
Angeles horseback riding and we're here
to learn how to ride a horse I've never
ridden a horse in my life I don't think
I've ever been near a horse actually
I've been near a horse once when I was a
kid there was some restaurant that had
horses and I like saw him through the
fence and like I was just looking at it
over there and it got real closely like
a like swung up besides the fence not so
close that I could touch her anything
but it was just right there I was like
oh it's a horse and I just started
peeing all over the ground and like it
splattered all over my shoes so that was
my first experience with a horse and now
I'm going to meet to Barney hi Barney
and that's Jason yeah do I come over
there okay
[Music]
so it's immediately to the getting on
there's no like saying hello to the
horse oh okay I didn't know if there was
hello this is Barney communicate
Barney you're just a big sweetie aren't
you
I've never pet a horse before you're so
cool they're so big your head is huge
do they like scratches or oh not like my
dog my love dog loves just be slapped
and pat it all over real thumped but not
you they are like dogs the more you
communicate with them the more they'll
understand you - how old is Barney
parties in this teenager years all right
one two three four left okay perfect
great how are you feeling wonderful yes
okay this is your horn horn horn yes
hand on horns okay I am breathing is it
normal to feel a sense of power yes okay
good right so it's like a mind over
matter kind of thing do you ride dirt
bikes no I own a bicycle I didn't say I
rode the bicycle so it's like you know
how actors they just say they're an
actor and then they're an actor so if I
say I'm a sir I'm I'm a sir
what's a sir
a person who horses I thought that was
self-explanatory see how he took a deep
breath so did you and now you're holding
your breath we have to be one of body of
mind right so I've played like Red Dead
Redemption how accurate is that to
real-life horsing almost spot-on yeah
really
oh wow I just played the sequel and it
was super fun I often ended up throwing
my horses like accidentally driving them
off mountains because not intentionally
no this was not an intentional thing I
didn't mean to drive them off mountains
but I was always impatient so I was
sprinted to the next place as fast as
possible and you'd get markers on your
map and I wouldn't know that it'd just
be a drop-off so I'm not gonna do that
today that's not gonna happen
I want to be very clear neck rein turn
this hand towards the towards the
mountain and he'll turn to the right
right neutral so it's like a gearbox
this frame to the left or to the left
neutral oh and then release
middle middle how'd that go it's like a
gearbox correct to move him forward easy
stand heels down heels down heels down
toes up
always always heels to the dirt heels to
the dirt toes toes to this guy to move
your horse forward this is the rib cage
right here yes and you're bringing your
toes out like you're doing happy feet
and you're squeezing with your calves
into their ribs both legs and say walk
on walk on squeeze walk on hey little
right wow I'm just training for my
future role on Game of Thrones I mean I
know the season the whole series is
ending but maybe there'll be a spinoff
oh this is fun right why do I need to
know the county everything what am i
what am i clapping exactly so trot is
one two one two
what's an all-out sprint so I can avoid
it a quick one two three four okay does
this horse even go that fast okay if
this horse was like a car
what equivalent car would it be like the
top-line racing horse Lamborghini
Ferrari Tesla just like a Toyota Corolla
is a Bentley Barney the bed never been
in one but I imagine it's like that okay
you're squeezing with your thighs
in your paths and more you keep yourself
relaxed oh you're rocking yourself like
this like you're on a swing set you
might bounce when you start bouncing a
little bit maybe slightly lean back and
keep those bouncers much okay squeeze
and ask them to trot kick with your legs
okay ready yes
trot thank you
oh good great even I've never been more
relaxed I might break this horn I'm
squeezing it so hard I'm good no I'm
great this feels good I feel good oh
great even better than before if I start
crying it's only because it's so
beautiful so on a scale of like 1/2 the
best you've ever seen
first-timer experience how I am how do I
rate well I didn't really have that kind
of number scale going on a four what's
the max number and you're in your mind
all right well what could I do to be
better before floor feels appallingly
below average
Noah four is not really good a four is a
four out of ten that's a failing grade
that's below average would you say I'm
above average then I would be like a six
at least look at tens like the best five
if it's if the standardized bell curve
it's gonna be a five is going to be the
standard average
I don't believe you but I'll take it
I like it yeah I feel good I didn't even
know I was moving forward frankly it was
so one with this with Barney trot
trot Erica I'm tall for once in my life
I'm tall I'm so proud I've never been
more proud of anything in my life
oh sorry almost ran you over
thank you that was innate I'm climbing
I'm a see alright just like my grades in
college they're jealous don't worry I'll
get to you soon
cut a graduate from Barney first not to
curse myself but has anyone ever here
suffered any cataclysmically horrible
disfiguring maybe accidents the long
pause you had suggested otherwise but
okay good yeah right right
oh you're so good Barney Barney you're
so good you're good my dog back home
who's your good boy good boy
so good Wow to make him move you really
got a kick kick kick as hard you can't
just make him go okay you guys go huh
okay pick up that speed right and when
he does start it's like you're rocking
on a rocking horse ah as soon as that as
soon as his head goes up your body is
going forward okay his head goes down
your body is sitting back into that
sound okay so it's just like I'm letting
my body be jello up here and I just like
go with the flow and it's like you know
it's like if I had a self-driving car I
just turn on autopilot and it goes right
okay cool
Oh Tanner cancer Oh cancer whoo oh my
god whoo
you said it'd be more comfortable yeah I
was trotting not canter got it all right
what was good great until you until I
say you got it Oh got it
keep squeezing don't give up the squeeze
okay I I imagine that there's very
little I could do to hurt this horse
yeah pretty sturdy right would you boys
you good boy
oh that's a long neck so stay relaxed
kick hard
[Music]
HUP whoa oh-ho
how's the canter okay yeah yeah I just
had this tendency to like I want to get
as low as possible yeah I got real
bouncy you see what I like I said in the
beginning it's the first bounce but when
she wrote it you've passed me because
you got comfortable and that was really
well done
Oh was I not supposed to pass thank you
do that one more time
nice move on what's the next one unless
you think I should you're the expert
what's your hard time all right
hop up
hup-hup
keep going oh oh I have it okay well if
I'm relaxed say I lose my grip on it and
then it slides this okay I'm trying to
relax as much as I can how do i what
was it slow right don't you sing relax
sit up tall they're two different
emotional states for me yeah perfect
okay oh I feel like I'm getting worse I
always have this weird bell curve on
things that I do where it's like all
right really concentrate and then I
actually try to execute some technique
and it goes real downhill real fast so I
wouldn't be surprised if I'm downgrading
from my eight yeah what point do I start
jumping over like fences and barriers
and stuff like that now okay so like in
ten minutes
[Music]
hup-ho oh that was nine nine or nice
nice oh okay right I feel like if I'm
relaxed though my limbs go floppy and
they kind of just like go or am I
actually like flapping okay that's not
good is between the ears I didn't know
that it's like targeting up Cantor
Cantor keep going oh right OOP sorry
sorry Barney I know it's confusing I'm
getting judgmental looks from these
other horses I feel like they know I I
don't belong here
how long have you been working with
horses since your two when you were two
years old were you better than I am
right now
[Laughter]
in the air yeah nice but I am always
proud of myself all right
hoo-hoo thousands nine I'm going up I'm
gonna get that perfect ten at some point
yeah okay I just got to separate my
upper body in my lower body cuz when I
when I kick my legs out my arms
automatically want to flail that is me
that's an apt addition of Who I am yes
right okay I always forget that I need
to push forward yeah yeah good boy good
boy up Cantor oh ho ho I'm thinking I'm
thinking this is real fun I'm thinking
Barney loves me or at least moderately
tolerates me love's a strong word
especially considering we just met but I
have a great deal of respect for things
that are taller than me
so I have a healthy amount of respect
for this horse and I haven't even more
respect for things that are heavier than
me so it's pretty close but I think this
words edges me out yeah I feel pretty
good I mean honestly what else is there
to learn oh I'm good good oh yeah
training my whole life for this
all right Barney is gonna touch you
first awesome that's what I was hoping
for
beautiful I've never had my hand flatter
okay so apparently I got score nine from
Jason and that's unprecedented here at
this at Los Angeles horseback you can
find out more information at Los Angeles
horseback riding comm either way for me
never being on a horse before that was
great
it was great it was 100% good great
experience
the the rumors are true about how if
you're riding kind of hurts a very
specific region that may have been
because I was bouncing too much but
isn't that pretty good I enjoyed myself
that was fun
look at me old pro I'm a 10 now Wow we
doing a figure eight turn to the left go
towards the tree turn right
well why'd get it right the left look at
me look at me
[Music]
also I'm definitely starting to feel it
in my thighs just the squeeze yeah oh
yeah there you go
come on oh my god it is my thighs you're
good you're good boy you're good boy
ah you're a good boy do these muscles
eventually develop and get stronger I've
never used these muscles - game day in
my life I always see that machine at the
gym the one that you wear your thighs
squeeze like you never actually used it
I should say yeah okay why am I out of
breath
[Music]
oh no I'm losing great it's like I'm
down to a three prolly where you've been
grading me this whole that is true that
is that is very true
okay all right that's true okay I'm
having fun Emma
[Music]
whoo okay oh I did it I did it you know
oddly enough I never I never thought of
like horseback riding as something fun
but this is really fun like I said the
beginning of this I sarcastically was
like do I feel a sense of power but I
really do like there's something about
such a good boy
well you know I actually think that that
might be enough so honestly thank you so
much without such a good teacher I doubt
I'd have gotten this far but yeah I know
honestly like I mean you obviously could
tell the house I was nervous getting on
here but I feel I feel so much better
now okay oh so good good Barney remember
that they're not therapy not what was
the other lesson RISP I have some moral
conclusion I'll write it in later my
moral conclusion is I'll put it in later
Barney you you for my first horse Barney
I really gotta say you made this special
for me and I got a thank you thank you
so much thank you so much oh that's nice
that's nice hi
I wrote a horse thank you Jason
for helping me out well I don't have a
lot of experiences in this but you seem
like you do an incredible job at it
because if anyone can teach me how to do
something then they got to be good so
thank you so much and thank you
everybody for watching if you've got
other ideas for things that I can try
let me know down in the comments if you
want to try horseback riding yourself
and you're in the LA area try out Los
Angeles horseback riding comm or just
look them up they're up here in old
Topanga Canyon Los Angeles horseback
riding check it out I'll put a link in
the description too so thank you
everybody so much for watching
oh yeah and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye I do
I've never never no no I've never I've
never ridden a horse before hey wait we
got addendum post-credit Jason really
thought that I had ridden before that's
amazing because that means I'm even
better than I think I know yeah I've
never never ever ridden before
yeah thank you
Game of Thrones hire me kill me off in
one episode I don't care all right
no real goodbye see ya
[Music]
you